Speaker 1: Let's go next to Brett from Indianapolis.
Brett, you on the air.
Speaker 2: Good to hear from you again.
Pleasure.
Yeah.
So I am going to be quick.
So I want to ask you, do you think you know
who I refused to say his name.
He just makes me so much.
Do you think he will go down as the number
one worst president in history, or do you
think at least the top five worst?
Speaker 1: Well, the top five worst out of
how many?
If this country lasts another five thousand
years, it you know, we could have a lot of
really bad PR.
I just think there's no way to answer those
questions.
You know, what we can say is Donald Trump
represented a huge inflection point in the
basement of the office of the presidency.
He is the worst president in recent political
history.
But any kind of long term pronouncements,
who knows?
It's very hard to make those predictions and
not particularly useful either.
Speaker 2: Right?
I mean, I feel like, you know you know, a
person like Hitler, he was certainly studied
a lot.
And there's certainly some changes that were
made after, you know, Germany because of what
happened to Hitler.
And I feel like he could have some repercussions
as to, you know, changes made because of his
presidency.
We will
Speaker 1: see.
We will see there should be consequences both
for Trump.
And I mean, listen, one of the things we learned
under Trump was the safeguards we thought
we had in place in case like a really horrible
person got elected.
Many of those safeguards clearly aren't strong
enough because Donald Trump so far has skated
with no consequences.
But we'll see.
Hopefully there will be consequences.
Speaker 2: But yeah.
And do you feel that it is important that
we.
Give him media attention because I had a German
friend, so I'll sum up the story.
He said, why do you guys still give Trump
attention?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I've talked about this before.
He is for now the most prominent Republican
and still the leader of the Republican Party,
which is one of only two major parties in
the U.S.
So to just ignore him for the sake of ignoring
him doesn't really make sense, given that
he does have the vast majority of his 74 million
voters still follow the guy and would follow
him to another party or vote for him again.
So he's relevant in American politics.
And I know you can say, well, he's only relevant
because people talk about him.
He still has seventy four million followers.
That's the reality.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Of my German friend was like, well, why don't
you guys just ignore him?
And I said, how does it work out for you guys
when you ignored Hitler?
Speaker 1: Yeah, fair.
Fair.
I like that.
I like where you're going with that, Bret.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
All right.
They're talking again.
Speaker 1: OK, thanks, Bret.
Bret from Indianapolis getting right to it.
Fantastic.
Let's go next to how about Román from Pittsburgh.
Roman, you're on the air.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: So I mostly wanted to talk about
the New York election that's happening.
I was very interested in the change in the
voting policies that they are enacting.
I think it actually has a lot of potential
nationally, nationally as well, to cause some
actual, like, moderation in the candidates
that kind of have a chance of getting elected.
Speaker 1: Sorry, are you talking about the
New York City mayoral race?
Yes.
Oh, and what changes that they make?
I've not been following or maybe I've forgotten
Speaker 2: they transferred to like like a
standard transferable vote or like
Speaker 1: a single transferable vote, OK?
Yeah.
Got it.
Yeah, I'm a big advocate of.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I was just curious if you
thought that that would have an ability to
affect presidential elections in a positive
way?
Speaker 1: Yes, I do.
And I've been talking about this for a long
time.
The combination of doing campaign finance
reform and getting away from first past the
post towards something like single transferable
vote, I think it would it's impossible to
overstate how much it would do.
It would allow third parties to really have
a shot.
It would make hopefully a lot of Americans
kind of rethink how we approach elections.
I've been advocating for for both of those
things for a really long time.
I think it would be great.
Speaker 2: Kind of continuing off of that.
Do you think that that that would kind of
hide like so?
Part of what I think is currently wrong with
the elections is that primaries sort of allow
for the most extreme candidate to push through
a lot of their ideology to because most people
who vote in primaries are either, like highly
engaged in the situation or, you know, have
more extreme beliefs.
Yeah, I think that allowed for Donald Trump
to sort of get, you know, more heinous ideas
out there to get support from the people who
are more engaged in the and the primaries.
Speaker 1: That may be more true on the Republican
side.
I mean, look, if you looked at the Democratic
primary of twenty twenty, the guy who had
more support than we thought was Biden, who
was not the most extreme candidate by any
means, in fact, to a fault, he's completely
uncontroversial and not extreme in any way.
So I don't know that that's necessarily true
at the national level.
But it's certainly plausible that in certain
maybe within the Republican Party or in certain
parts of the country, it might be true.
Speaker 2: Do you think that might be a result
of the ways that the Democrats have changed
their primary system?
Speaker 1: Well, tell me how you imagine that
that would be the case.
Speaker 2: One twenty sixteen.
There was a very close race between Clinton
and Bernie, and there had been some changes
that people kind of were insinuating kind
of flattened some of that support so that
it would allow the most popular candidate
to kind of take charge over time.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, so I don't I don't
know exactly what you're referring to, but
the superdelegates are voting on the first
round at the convention, which was eliminated
in.
Right.
So, yeah, I'm just I'm just not sure about
that.
But all important questions.
Speaker 2: All right.
I appreciate hearing from you and you actually
have some or some some support from Pennsylvania
and Pittsburgh, you know, most of that's super
red and super.
Problematic, but you have some some blue dots
around there.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you so much, Román.
Appreciate the call.